here with uh more reaction the author of
america a redemption story south
carolina tim scott you know senator i'd
rather talk about your incredible life
story because the book is phenomenal
i've read it cover to cover
um and i had the honor of meeting your
family uh it's great to have you first
your reaction all of this and then we'll
give you a little
opportunity to talk about the book
sean this is absurd think about it this
has been a wish hunt for six years think
about the steele dossier the russia
collusion two failed impeachment
attempts
and even more i can't imagine how anyone
in our country doesn't look at this with
eyes of suspicion there's no question in
my mind that this is an overreach at
best and frankly asking for a criminal
warrant that gives you a space of time
between august the 5th and august of
19th because they're looking for
national security sensitive information
there's nothing that comes to the
conclusion that you would ever give
someone two weeks to go through that
process this is devastating we're in
unchartered waters it is stunning to our
country and frankly this is something we
have to continue to dig into we got to
win the majority sean so that we can
actually go through the oversight in the
majority of this process
one thing i found interesting uh and i
had a chance to meet your family one day
um and
i don't know if you really want me to
talk about it but it is in your book
uh that you you were failing out in your
first year of high school you got four
fs yes and in civics there's one english
and spanish was another and i i don't
remember the fourth one
um world geography world geography what
did you what changed your life around
and i want people to read the book so
they get the full flavor of it
yeah thank you in my in my book america
redemption story one of the things i
cover sean is how really good people a
guy named john moniz a chick-fil-a
operator came into my life he happened
to be a christian conservative and he
started telling me about taking
individual responsibility looking in the
mirror and blaming myself if i'm not
happy with where i am the one thing that
we don't see today in america is the doj
taking responsibility for their actions
the leaks someone should be fired for
those leaks and that's one of the
reasons why i think my book is more
important today than it's ever been
because we literally are living in the
times of incredible polarization we can
bridge that gap but it requires
republicans and democrats to want an
equal application of the justice system
not one where your foot is literally on
the scale because you don't like the
former president
would you ever be a vice president if
asked by donald trump
you know that would be an incredible
honor i know that the list is long no
doubt about that i have lived an amazing
american dream i am so thankful to be
where i am but i guarantee you this my
shoulder will be to the to the
grindstone as it relates to making sure
that we take back not only the majority
but the white house
and you got an important senate race and
we're supporting your campaign your life
story is amazing and i hope people get
your redemption story because it is
inspiring beyond words thank you sir for
being with us we appreciate it hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else